bonjour à tous bonjour merci d'être avec
nous ce matin vous êtes effectivement
chargé de la jeunesse et du service
national universel mais on va d'abord
parler de vos fonctions politiques si
j'ose dire vous êtes vice-présidente du
MoDem l'un des piliers d'une majorité
relative qui est mise à rude épreuve
depuis maintenant 10 jours à l'Assemblée
nationale hier soir le deuxième volet de
des dispositions sur le pouvoir d'achat
ont été votés avec le budget
rectificatif mais le gouvernement a dû
s'inclinaire plusieurs reprises un
milliard d'euros de dépenses
supplémentaires ont été décidées par les
oppositions il va falloir s'habituer à
cette co-construction de la loi
construire la loi c'est ça aller
chercher du débat c'est bien et c'est le
message des Français c'est ce qu'on
souhaitait les Français avoir une
majorité
relative d'être le premier groupe mais
d'aller chercher du consensus et on voit
bien que ce consensus il s'inscrit il
s'écrit avec LR avec le Parti socialiste
mais ce qui m'a ce qui m'inquiète le
point sur lequel faut être vigilant et
encore plus parce qu'on a un taux
d'abstention extrêmement élevé et que je
le vois chez les jeunes je vois à quel
point il déserte cette confiance dans
notre politique dans la vie politique de
notre pays et bien c'est l'outrage c'est
l'outrans c'est
aux parties extrémiste entre guillemets
mais c'est ce qu'on voit l'assemblée
c'est des mots de plus en plus violents
outrageux insultant hier est-ce que vous
pensez vraiment que arriver à
l'Assemblée de la République en marche
on a vu des dérapages y compris sur les
bandes
et je crois que à chaque dérapage il
faut une sanction mais pour le pouvoir
d'achat des Français pour répondre à ces
prioritaires absolument essentiels
est-ce que arrivé en cravatée sur
sur le parvis de l'Assemblée pour faire
des coups de buzz c'est ce qui fera
évoluer aujourd'hui le pouvoir d'achat
des Français la réponse est non donc je
pense qu'il faut revenir un peu à
l'essentiel de cette assemblée il se
trouve que je suis député j'ai siéger
sur ses bancs le compromis le consensus
est bon c'est sain pour notre pays pas
l'outrage et pas des coups de l'écoute
comme ou les coups de base les coudes
comme les outrages comme vous les
appelez est-ce que c'est la seule raison
des blocages qu'on a connu est-ce que
par exemple une démonstration qui est
faite aujourd'hui avec la décision de ne
pas siéger en septembre pour que le
gouvernement puisse mieux préparer ses
textes est-ce qu'il y a pas aussi une
responsabilité des ministres des
secrétaires d'État de travailler en
amont avec les députés pour ne pas avoir
les quoique que l'on a connu pendant ces
derniers jours qui nous a été proposée
qui nous a été demandé par le le
président de la République et par la
première ministre plus travailler les
textes plus prendre plus de temps pour
le faire mais votre part
je pense qu'il y a beaucoup de choses à
améliorer la méthode évidemment c'est
notre souhait c'est que ça fonctionne
dans l'intérêt des Français c'est notre
seul boussole par contre quand on dépose
des amendements avec le seul but
d'écrire en fumage je suis désolé c'est
simplement enfumé la démocratie et
malheureusement ne pas aller chercher le
consensus
sera compliqué est-ce que les réformes
finalement promises par Emmanuel Macron
lors de sa réaction et bien pourront
être tout simplement voté si ça continue
comme ça comme on a connu ces derniers
jours depuis mes 18 ans j'aime la vie
politique je crois que c'est ce qui
transforme la vie et j'ai la conviction
que oui avec les élus les plus
responsables parce que les Français sont
témoins de ce qui se passe et bien on
réussira à faire que leur intérêt soit
la priorité de notre quotidien ça veut
dire qu'avec les LR ça veut dire qu'avec
le Parti socialiste avec toutes les
sensibilités de la majorité et
certainement avec des hommes et les
femmes qui sortiront des postures
politiciennes de l'Assemblée pour aller
voter ce qui est important dans la vie
quotidienne des Français on construira
cette majorité alors Sarah on en vient à
vos fonctions spécifiques maintenant au
sein du gouvernement vous êtes on le
disait chargé de la jeunesse du service
national universel on est le 27 juillet
au cœur de l'été beaucoup d'enfants de
jeunes sont à sont en vacances pas tous
on y reviendra mais pour ceux qui ont la
chance d'être au grand air en colonie de
vacances en particulier il y a un
problème c'est que cette année il y a
une pénurie d'animateurs très
présente très voyante dans un certain
nombre de centres quel est l'état des
lieux déjà et surtout quelle solution
vous proposez pour y remédier partir en
colonie de vacances c'est pas simplement
partir en vacances c'est une aventure
qui est assez exceptionnelle et entre
nous c'est un petit trésor français
c'est un trésor du patrimoine français
et aujourd'hui mais aujourd'hui il est
en crise c'est une réalité il y a une
crise des vocations il y a une pénurie
et de l'attention comme dans beaucoup de
métiers mais ça c'est pas pareil à
encadrer des enfants les accompagner
c'est il faut accompagner ces vocations
donc il faut répondre de manière très
claire à des à une meilleure
rémunération à une meilleure gestion
améliorer la rémunération il faut
améliorer également la gestion de la
formation l'accompagnement l'accès au
BAFA et c'est pour ça que sous l'ancien
quinquennat j'avais lancé le plan
animation donc des concertations avec
principalement les acteurs donc les
enseignants les associations d'éducation
populaire les collectivités pourquoi
parce que plus que jamais il faut donner
les moyens d'avoir de nouveaux jeunes
qui s'engagent dans le BAFA dans le BAFD
justement vous rappelez le précédent
quinquennat malgré ce que vous avez fait
on en revient en constat cet été il y a
un manque cruel d'animateur des colonies
de vacances qui ne peuvent pas
accueillir d'enfants quel est finalement
ce que vous qu'est-ce que vous allez
faire là maintenant concrètement de
manière dès septembre le comité de du
monde de l'animation que j'ai installé
se réunira pour faire les rebelles
horizons et les conditions de travail on
permettra également et j'écrirai dès
demain au 145 000 jeunes qui font une
mission service civique de continuer
leur mission de service civique en
passant le BAFA ou le BAFD parce que ce
sont des jeunes engagés et c'est la
suite du parcours et je aiderai
financièrement avec 100 euros pour
accompagner ce passage parce qu'il y a
aussi un coût pour le BAFA et de l'autre
côté 100 € pour tous les jeunes tous les
jours passés le BAFA sont en service ici
mais aussi on permettra à tous ces
jeunes de passer le BAFA dans leur lycée
donc plus proche encore de chez eux vous
savez le BAFA c'est il y a des freins
parfois le coup et aujourd'hui il y a
pas mal de collectivités qui est déjà
mais moi je veux revenir à l'ADN même du
décoloni de vacances c'est d'abord des
parents qui nous font confiance il faut
qu'on soit à la hauteur de cette
confiance ils nous mettent entre les
mains leurs trésor leur joyau c'est le
moment on a les premiers souvenirs les
premiers amours parfois souvent les
premiers départs et il est et mon
obsession c'est de ne pas faire que
certains jeunes ne puissent pas partir
parce qu'il n'y a pas d'encadrant alors
oui à cette crise d'évocation on
répondra par de la rémunération mais
aussi le ressources le retour vers les
encadrants ils ont été moins nombreux à
passer le BAFA aussi à cause de la du
covid depuis deux ans est-ce que se
rattrapage pourra finalement et bien
faire en sorte qu'il y ait jusqu'à la
fin de cet été suffisamment d'encadrant
dans les colonies de vacances est-ce que
certaines colonies vont devoir fermer ou
limiter en tout cas leur accueil
malheureusement il y a des parts qui ont
déjà été annulés et moi ma mission c'est
que il n'est pas de jeunes qui ne
puissent pas partir alors même que ses
parents nous font confiance pour vivre
cette aventure qui fait grandir vous
savez la colonie de vacances c'est dans
c'est dans la communauté éducative c'est
un des maillons de cette chaîne et donc
on y apprend on y apprend différemment
mais c'est important ça oxygène moi ma
mission c'est que dans les lycées on en
parle dans qu'on lève les freins
financiers avec la CAF la CNAV avec les
collectivités plus attractif parce que
plus de formation plus de parcours et
plus de rémunération des colonies de
vacances donc des enfants qui ont la
chance de pouvoir y partir un enfant sur
quatre ne part pas en vacances c'est
aussi une réalité alors il y a beaucoup
de villes qui organisent à Paris des
plages sur place mais qu'est-ce que vous
allez dans l'état vous faites pour
favoriser le départ en vacances de de
tous ces enfants qui qui sont 4 millions
4 millions un jeune sur trois ne part
pas alors quand on ne peut pas partir et
bien il faut qu'on puisse s'oxygéner
c'est pour ça qu'on a mis en place ce
qu'on appelle vacance apprenantes alors
c'est plein d'action vous savez que ce
soit pour les jeunes qui sont dans des
quartiers prioritants de la ville donc
plutôt dans des quartiers difficiles des
quartiers populaires il y a aussi des
jeunes ruraux des jeunes en situation de
handicap et pour tous ces jeunes qui ne
peuvent pas partir on a fait quoi
quartier d'été le patrimoine à vélo lors
des pros l'école des pros l'école
buissonnière tout ça c'est quoi et bien
c'est plus de 180 millions d'euros qui
sont investis c'est plus de 2000
établissements qui sont ouverts pour des
activités artistiques touristiques où on
s'amuse
c'est ma mission c'est exactement ma
mission plus le faire connaître et dire
aux parents surtout
tournez-vous vers soit un jeune une
solution ce qui est un site internet
soit mon site jeune.gouv.fr parce qu'il
y a des réponses il y a des solutions il
faut grandir il y a une autre
institution que vous devez faire mieux
connaître manifestement c'est le service
national universel vous êtes en charge
dans le libellé de votre ministère de
cette de ce nouveau service finalement
qui ne fait pas tant recettes que qu'on
l'espérait que vous l'espériez quelques
dizaines de milliers de jeunes pour
l'instant font leur SNU comment vous
expliquer ce succès mitigé c'est un
succès aujourd'hui le sinus c'est quoi
parce que beaucoup de personnes se
passent c'est le service national
universel c'est une aventure unique
c'est un nouveau droit c'est un droit
pour notre jeunesse un droit à
l'engagement 70
000 entre 2000 à peu près 2019 et
aujourd'hui mais ce nouveau droit
deviendra et je crois que ce sera notre
réussite un devoir pour cette jeunesse
parce qu'elle aura conscience que c'est
fait pour elle pour qu'elle puisse
s'engager et prendre sa place c'est
l'excellence de l'éducation nationale
l'excellence de l'éducation populaire et
l'excellence de nos coron uniformes
c'est une aventure unique mais est-ce
qu'il devrait pas rendre c'est une
promesse d'Emmanuel Macron ce service
national universel obligatoire pour pour
le rendre non pas attractif mais comme
son nom l'indique accessible et
obligatoire pour tout le monde ma
mission qui est ce nouveau droit parce
que c'est un nouveau droit permettra un
jeune de partir en dehors de son
département on vient d'en parler de
découvrir des jeunes différents qui sont
très différents de lui de découvrir tous
les champs de l'action de associative ou
des réserves c'est un droit moi je ferai
que les jeunes considèrent que ce soit
un devoir pour que ce soit tellement
attractif ma mission d'Emmanuel Macron
la généralisé avant la fin du
quinquennat du président donc on vous a
entendu merci beaucoup Sarah alayhi
secrétaire d'État donc chargé de la
jeunesse et on vient d'en parler du
service national universel très bonne
journée suite de Télématin merci
beaucoup